yeah okay this is nuggets of employment
chelation Kayden we started off with a
whole bunch of variations on this
plastic movement is made its way into
your 50 most typically done over to the
elbow or the shoulder so bodyspace to be
explored you do the same motion under
your leg this one has two schools of
thought how to do it one is just moving
your hand very very quickly school which
snapback get the boy before it starts to
college a family's the second school is
that of stalling at the tether as it
goes through to give you a little bit
more of a window grab it also played
with doing this over our neck big tip
for that is tilting your neck it's just
about horizontal in that question and
approaching your neck like so so that
the palm of your hand is up against your
neck now position the tether in a way it
is easily caught and they won't
spaces are improved we also did it
behind our backs this is where that
float talked about earlier really comes
in there's so much larger distance to
cover so can do the vast improvements
dial well that's we also went over slaps
on their best done we started just with
a flow through right here where there's
no no motion happening boy they take
another hand and slapping it slap it in
any direction lunch you'll find that
once I get these power of your slap
right that ants can make a full rotation
yes one hand as blue slap feels really
good slaps you right back up right back
we also went over slapping grip head of
your boy stole its heather outward as if
you're going to do this catch right here
instead of a nice soft touch slap it
down hot the first one if they reduces
slapping against resistance of the
direction of the poison already moving
can also be done to a variety of spaces
back around in it next looked at doing a
throw of the contain under day trips
degrees of One Direction a slap in first
degree of the other direction even we
have time to do that is to start with an
underthrown so
that one that requires easily the most
horse of a flux got to give it enough
boom counteract this B that's already
going out and to get it all the way back
or catch it is possible to do with
standard throw first where doesn't feel
very good Smart's it's much little bit
after that worked with these Baptists
out of this position which squeeze catch
with the elbow announcing it off of the
leg pendulum that is oriented top and
bottom instead of side to side so the
leg it'll be good at sharing it with so
have hand head I'm creasing you keep you
all around the other side you absolutely
can the big challenge there is that it's
wrapped around and so he's decided
kissing on also need with this shoulder
place here great subtle little piece of
anusha taking the hedge and uniform
you're placing it on too far down and
allow each other to swing on the back
kos very minimal grabby fueled trick we
also played with this boy is throwing
it's top of the shoulder
we looked at the Rope contacting the
body style throws dash this one from
Keith as well as the arm movement right
as well well ask horizontal version not
only another body had his throne and
forcefully back Heather and I was
equally hot
the ends
he looked ass with Gradle pitches Sox
planet or e some of the ways in which
also played with elation because i was
taking them two sides go to around
little directionless walking boy various
places is each other
mol Superman's oh and we Superman real
well great joy strikes one's heart
moment joy and blow turquoise it's
delightful filter boy into we snap
wonder zoo around the pendulum version
purpose also the white bowl and tiny
match is actually she did it you also
forgot this second inmate one second
another say you know where you go like
this that's not actively off so how you
combine all those nuggets very carefully
what
kayden Hurst yes point nuggets workshop
fire drums 1998-99 a date my stuff just
kidding 2014 fire Trump's beautiful
redwood forests